tout le monde découvre ici si c'est
parce un chopper c'est ici c'est le long
du fleuve aucune sur 7 sur cette piste
cyclable qu'on appelle de greenway
vraiment l'autoroute des vélos on peut
aller partout très très rapidement en
empruntant cet esclave et lorsqu'on voit
bien qu'il ya des terrains de basketball
des terrains pour les skateboards les
rouli roulant comme je vous l ai parc
pour les enfants parcourent les chiens
donc vraiment une zone pour les new
yorkais que les new yorkais utilise
beaucoup ici la fin de semaine là
surtout qu'on est dans la période de
l'entraînement pour le marathon de new
york qui bientôt il ya tellement
joggeurs cette fin de semaine qu'on peut
même pas marcher